Hello, everybody. Welcome to another holistic health hour. This is Dr. Kevin Conners. Let's jump right into it. We have some questions that were sent in there. All right. What is the difference between an allergy to food and a sensitivity food? I think they're saying it.
So it's really a matter of semantics to a degree. So typically a food sensitivity. It has to do with the different immutable globulums that are fiery. That's a part of your immune response.
When you talk about it like a peanut allergy, that's an IGG, that's an IGE reaction. And that is a more of an immediate immune response that could cause hyperinflation and even lead to death because the hair, the person's airways can be blocked.
So we're talking typically about a food sensitivity. We're talking about a delayed response, an IGG response, and that is more of a delayed response.
Food sensitivity to gluten. Let's say you have IGG antibodies to gluten. That's not the same as full celiac disease. Well, the person with celiac disease is exposed to gluten can get such severe pain in their abdominal area that they could end up in the ER.
And you know, could have quite a lot of damage to their intestinal tract versus somebody with an IGG reaction to gluten will have a ramped up inflammation that could be just as damaging systemically, but not as damaging specifically to the gut wall and something like an acute reaction like that.
So that's really the difference. But for most people, it's more semantic. So when you go and you say, I like you're at a restaurant is this gluten free now they say, is this an allergy or sensitivity reason is that if you have celiac disease, they're not going to serve you anything because their kitchen isn't a pure celiac.
They have gluten, clean kitchen, they have other products in there that have gluten in it and maybe your food is going to be served with, you know, gluten free bread, but there's no guarantee that it's that, you know, something else wasn't fried of that same griddle that had bread, you know, that has gluten in it.
So you could still have a reaction if you had full celiac disease. So if you do have full celiac or IGG peanut allergy, you have to be far more careful getting around somebody with peanuts, some people with celiac can't even walk, can't even go grocery shopping because they can't go in the bakery section because breeding in that
gliated that may be floating in the air could cause a reaction and cause issues. So that's really the difference. So you should say if you have, you did a Syracist 3 or 10 that you show different food allergies, technically their food sensitivities, technically you do have an allergy, you have antibodies to that thing.
And it is serious, but it's typically not immediately like threatening that's really different.
How do I decide between different products for phase 6 of the patient detoxification process.
So if you haven't read my book, seven pages of detox, you know, what this question is about the base success to do with proper elimination.
And in the book and in the course, I talk about different products that you could use to help with elimination.
And it is a little bit of a trial and error because it is, if you are on the course, you know, I'm not giving you direct advice as, you know, a patient because we don't have patients, we have members.
So it is a trial and error and it is about looking at other products that you might already have in the cupboard. I've got here just to sell products. I don't want the courses to be just to sell products. I want you to look at the ingredients of the products that I recommend and you might have a cover for products already.
I mean, try to utilize those products, but understand, phase 6 is helping you with the detoxification pathway and phase 6 is helping you with elimination through that path and that piece of that pathway.
So some of the stakes that people make is they had somebody that they asked me why was taking an aloe product for my God today was really helping me.
Is it the same thing as the aloe that you recommend when I had to look at that product that they were taking it is not capable. So there is a lot of differences in the ingredients that might have aloe in the name, but it's the variety of aloe that's going to help with elimination.
So just typical aloe, which would be aloe armorescence can be very soothing for the intestinal tract, it can be very healing for the intestinal tract.
The typically isn't going to be really helping with elimination.
If you want to help with elimination, let's say you're constipated, then you really need to keep aloe if you're going to pick the aloe product that's a specific type of aloe.
With magnesium, you have a little bit more leeway magnesium glycinate is typically the product that might be recommended by a lot of practitioners.
If you're dealing with constipation because it can stay more in the gut and therefore draw more water and that's the whole idea.
So excess magnesium of any type, any variety, any type of collated magnesium.
If you take excess of it, it'll end up getting dumped in the gut and that will draw water and that will help with elimination as well.
We have multiple products that I recommend.
Some people there are real issue is the deficiency in fiber. There's not eating a lot of fiber rich foods, you know, salads, they don't eat vegetables.
It's just their eventual dietary pattern and it's just a change in diet.
It's going to help sometimes you're adding extra fiber that is a digestible fiber, which we typically recommend.
The sun spectrum or the sun fiber products that can be the thing that really helps the person. Some people are constipated because they have an imbalance and they're got lower and they really need probiotics.
So I'm all for using any of these products to help with constipation because you cannot be constipated.
But you do want to dig a little bit deeper eventually at some point of time to look at why am I constipated.
You know, I'm constipated because of my important bio and I'm constipated because I have a lot of inflammation in the gut.
So I need to do some other testing to find out any sources of inflammation that you need to deal with.
Do I need to dig to the reason why?
And I think yes, the answer is all these things. Yes.
So do do that, but do experiment.
I can't tell you exactly what's going to be best for you. You do need to do some experimentation in this process is going to.
I'm going to take you burberry for two weeks and for the past five days, I've felt nauseous, loose balls and crampied.
I'm not sure if the burberry is the culprit because the last time I took it, I had the same symptoms, but I did not.
But I did not make the connection then is there something else I can take.
So burberry is a natural product that's in different foods that's found in.
Or a great that's found in barberry, it's found in a few other things.
It's a great.
And I.
The Bionic to the gut.
It's one of my favorite things.
It can help lower blood sugar.
It's great for people with cancer because it can help decrease glucose sensitivity on cell membrane.
So it hinders the cancer cells ability to take up glucose.
It can, it can help kill H. Pylori, which is a kind of player in so many disorders.
really good for heart disease, buriburine,
so cardiovascular disease.
So I love buriburine.
I take buriburine quite frequently.
So, but it can be like anything
you can kind of have an irritation to it.
So it can be good to pulse your products.
Maybe just taking it every day is not the thing to do.
Maybe you just need to take it once a week.
Maybe you didn't take it a couple times a week.
Burberry might still be the right thing for you to take.
Maybe you just, everybody thinks
you know, you have to take your supplements
every single day.
So, and I might even recommend people take two a day at ease.
And, but the truth is is that you could have
to experiment with a little bit of pulsing your supplements.
So my pulsing, I think I have an article
about pulsing supplementation as a blog post
on our website, I want to look.
You can search for it at the search bar of our website.
The pulsing your supplementation means
sometimes it's good to take it, you know,
just four days a week or five days a week
or you're going to take the weekend off.
If you notice a sense,
timidity or a reaction to any supplement
then it can even pulsing a little bit differently.
Sometimes people are actually having a tummy ache
from the capsule itself.
So you can open up most supplements
of time release supplements.
You can open up those supplements
and put them in your smoothie.
You could put them in some other drink.
So I would try pulsing it before I would just discontinuing it.
Can a person have a sensitivity to burberry?
I've not known that.
Anything is possible.
Could you have a damage that order
that it's just being irritated by burberry?
That's possibility too.
Could the loose balls and balls and cramping
because the burberry is killing off age parlorae
or something and it actually being a good thing?
Well, that's a possibility too.
But that's no fun to ham.
So pulsing it could be better to maybe just kill
a little more slowly if that is the cause of this.
We just don't know you have to experiment
with some of those things like that.
All right, I hope this was a blessing to you.
And we'll see you next time.